not that that that thought before this
video begins I have another exciting
announcement wow there's a lot of those
feelings I have the Star Wars tied and
colliding Empire GPU you like GPUs of
course you do
I have also the Jedi version so I'm
doing a giveaway with lyric and origin
PC where it's worldwide so you can get
one of these just by signing up in the
link in the description oh my oh man
origin PC also have a Black Friday sales
right now so if you're looking to buy a
computer now it's a great time to do it
before Christmas
also the giveaway of getting my computer
is also available so check out that as
well enough okay enough I get it let's
start the video hello pass today we're
gonna review some memes that you've made
are you excited
let's go do you like my hair I like it a
lot and I'm a little self-conscious
about it so please don't write any mean
comments thank you who would win some of
the most respected news journals
respected really I don't think so
some [ __ ] specific I would probably
win at who's the most Swiss Jim see I've
been framed by the media guys I keep
telling you you haven't seen the full
picture I was just petting this innocent
little doubt it's like that that media
image there it is it's like that one you
didn't see the full picture I was just
petting it down an innocent down you
should be thanking me giving me awards
for being a good dog owner papa Frank of
promoting peopIe glasses before it was
mainstreamed I'm that [ __ ] took
my glasses guess why this man quit
soccer and how he is making billions and
millions on YouTube we look nothing
alike my beard is at least 10 times
better sorry whoever you are when you
have no ideas for a vid that is monetize
so you tell the stories on the internet
yet you just read recently I see Here I
am trying to make original content and
then it's just oh he just wants money
then what can we pick on him about this
time wait wait a minute he's making
original content we needed a new excuse
[ __ ] you're all [ __ ] guys
literally only want one thing and it's
effing disgusting Christian Channel fast
internet damn boy for pink damn damn oh
but what's your upload huh what's your
upload this is downloading them all
right PewDiePie giving his last brofist
before ending the channel 20 how do you
how would you even say that
23:18 whatever that's right I will take
on a sentient being I will become an AI
in the form of shaggy from scooby-doo
can you imagine my lifes brofist oh
that's right so you're filled with sad
news now and not joy Felix Arvid Ulf
Kjellberg artwork for PewDiePie shame
will be appreciated
Jesper that's [ __ ] dope is this drawn
or is it Photoshop it looks sick man a
very nice how-to handshake 101 shut the
[ __ ] up dammit I don't ever want to see
that [ __ ] again twisting channel yeah
you know what that is how you beautify
reuploading you have you loose videos
after YouTube texts it's funny cuz it's
true well Jeff play your effing thank
you for censoring appreciate it
Christian Channel
alright we're switching reddit so please
haha my name and just play them all play
them all at once I fear no man but that
thing it's good that's just [ __ ] mean
when you saw the new you laugh you lose
when it was first listen I had I may
have had a couple issues just a few
wishes on my last upload but it wasn't
my fault I'm trying to provide quality
family-friendly you know what I'm a nice
guy okay
I don't need to take this crap from you
guys because I am NOT just
family-friendly Felix I am nice guy
PewDiePie review fan work drink in the
house and tell Marseille it's for me
promote your shitty game you guys are
just so que me relief it's just behind
the meme in disguise no Anthony Fontana
used to have a show called meme review
it was shut down because the fader wrote
a slanderous article about him and it
was me I wrote the article so I can take
over meme review its original content
now because nothing else exists your
move melon head summary of this week's
you laugh you loose try again god dammit
2017 has just been a treat I know
everyone is trying to blame me for the
ad pocalypse okay I know you want a
scapegoat I know you want to point
fingers I'll use you fools what are you
complaining kids what came first the egg
or the chicken all right I'm the egg
blame the chicken please I didn't do
nothing
I'm nice guy PewDiePie family friendly
switched in channel I've improved and so
can you is to stop crying
[Music]
ah
my neighbor's hate me
amazing grande very you get a to knit
with two very nicest don't give out
those very often one pt PI headset 9999
77 copies of its everyday bro
bye Jake Paul 99 33 wow the choice is
obvious they both lead to cancer so I
guess you can't really go wrong I would
go with the bargain offer please
I'll have the 77 copies please thank you
there it is can you stop can you stop
can you thank you stop stop listen I'm
trying to promote it nice guy PewDiePie
image okay no more no more no more of
this no more damn nice it looks good I
look good tip tip can you spot the
difference
99% impossible holy [ __ ] I can't tell
them apart I need to get one of those
shinobi headbands I think they're pretty
cool trying out new games constantly
trying and failing at one game but it's
all good because you can't die and if
you eventually beat it you can yell
their death oh my god it's true and get
it I'm gonna beat the game everyone this
is why I have trust issues
Christian channel activated I don't
believe in religion no no I'm a
Christian channel that I was just saying
that prove a point
guys please listen twiston channel
forever for life
any other objective very hey very nice
meme scout tada Finola dude my dad this
translation is happened very nice it's
actually not perfectly correct grammar
but it's also very nice bike cuck my
show got cancelled recently I was pretty
bummed out about it but I think whoever
cancelled it was probably more happy to
get it cancelled than I am sad to get it
canceled what the heck the total
happiness in the world increased so
whatever look at my cute little face so
true
you know what suddenly I don't even care
that the show got canceled it's not like
it was the worst month of my life to
produce that shitty show but as long as
the total happiness in the world was
increased then I think it's okay as long
as everybody's happy but I still got
paid anyway students name the symbol oh
my god oh my god that's good very nice
IKEA [ __ ] [ __ ] how did this get to
the top page IKEA ea you can't get bad
reviews if game journals can't get past
the trattoria it's pretty smart in inter
and interent I don't think you
understand this me loss you laugh you
loose Christian channel original okay
fine fine haha you got you got a good
one
forty-year-old pewdiepie look it's me
meme review mira Nick that's it for this
episode
wait didn't I ask you to do the intro
where the [ __ ] are all my intros I
clearly have no control over this this
one one that's the winner
oh that's good that's [ __ ] good
Christian channel intro
[Music]
ah this is good - goddammit ah there's
an animator one very nice ah man so good
terabrite may one cold school original
ideas are fictional
[Music]
ultimately predictable
Hey new intro 100% original content I
[Music]
would say something mean but I'm nice
guy PewDiePie and that was a great intro
well done very nice that would be
ridiculous
[Music]
I ran out of ideas that's a good that's
a good title of it that's a good enemy
by the way that you should watch it okay
well done well done on these intros I
can't believe I almost forgot it next
week just post the dankest meme you
could find I challenge you brought squad
fam and leave a like I would appreciate
it see if we can get this on trending on
YouTube if everyone liked the video
we'll probably get two million likes and
if I get to mail in likes and finally
that will motivate me to make some
original content so thank you appreciate
it
and as always laughs you lose you get
there